the problem with being a billionaire
is you lose touch with reality if you're
not careful
i think elon is good at at least so far
maintaining touch with reality no but if
you look at the name of his child you
can clearly see
liz i do like him and i do think what
he's done with tesla you know my
producer is a tesla and he never shuts
up about it
most people that have tesla's never shut
up about them and they
talk they think they're part of the
development team at spacex and i i like
that he's created
a world where people can get excited
about a 37 000
car and never shut the [ __ ] up about it
to the point where i have to threaten
people with physical violence
to get them to stop telling me about
that their car drives itself oh you
should
have a few less drinks and a few a few
fewer vicodin
and you can drive yourself have you
thought about getting a tesla i've never
thought about i don't know
they're minimalist i don't like middle i
want more
i want more i want to trust i want to
see i'm just being
i want it i'm trolling my guy my
producer wants a cyber truck
i want a stage coach old-school stage
coach
horse thief [ __ ] that it's going worse
it's going back to that i live in an
area with a lot of horses it's going
back to like
whipping a horse i want an animal to
shriek while i go by
[Laughter]
you want more suffering in the world not
less oh i think we need it
okay but i just don't like that
billionaire
is a bad word and it's not necessary
sure not
every billionaire is a pedophile i know
but the problem is
a lot of like it's just you know epstein
was very smart at like just getting
people at that house and taking photos
of them
nobody knew what they were doing but
it's like it was one of those things
where it's like after
the most social guy ever like every
photo he's like hey
everyone that's ever done anything in
the world has been at that [ __ ]
island
every human being is like in a photo
it's just weird like i'm in like it's
funny me and my friends get together we
don't ever take photos right yeah
like last night a few people it was my
birthday yesterday i'm 17
and my my friends came over and we're
just eating dinner right
and we had a fun night just four people
that are over nobody right
nobody ever thought like let's let's hey
i want to remember it
let's take photos i'm 36
yeah but but everything epstein did
there's just photos
of everybody it's interesting
you